spain has become the biggest receiver of
migrants that have crossed the
Mediterranean welcoming almost 30,000
people just this year on Thursday 87
asylum seekers docked in the southern
Spanish port of Algeciras but the local
mayor claims that the city doesn't have
the resources to cope with the new
arrivals we were not informed of
anything as mayor I have to ensure
citizens interests and I don't want
social imbalance here the Spanish have
big hearts yes but on this issue we have
to use our heads because there is not
enough money over 23 thousand refugees
came to Spain by sea this year the
massive inflow has sparked concern among
people in the capital as well we need to
take more measures to help this migrants
in their countries of origin bodies
compete with each other such
grandstanding it's all about politics
they're simply playing with people
nobody modified we can't let these
people simply die in the sea but this
has been happening for a long time we'll
let these things happen again and again
on Saturday a new migrant deal between
Spain and Germany comes into force under
the agreement refugees travelling from
Spain can be returned there within 48
hours of arrival at the German border
here's how the German Interior Minister
described the deal thus what did he call
it the German governing coalition wants
a procedure with the main affected
countries to negotiate the process of
repatriation of migrants I hope that
soon we will get some clarity and see if
it works out in the end the German
people would not understand if we took
in more refugees than we sent back this
wouldn't fly politically the president
of the far-right Spanish party respeto
claims the country blindly follows any
orders from Germany acuerdo symbolic o
simplemente para la barra the only
purpose of this symbolic agreement is to
help merkel save face before her own
government which is in trouble right now
and of course Spain is going to
obediently take whatever Merkel throws
at us Europe cannot accept any more
migrants every week we see problems
plaguing Spanish cities all because
there's no way to control the inflow of
migrants and because there's no way to
give jobs to the newcomers all the while
thousands of skilled
Spanish people are leaving the country
every month we're not providing them
with opportunities we made the biggest
mistake a nation can make we have
forsaken our own children to take in
others
you